Пані заступнице держсекретаря, дякую вам за інтерв'ю,
ласкаво просимо в програму.
Держсекретар Майк Помпео в грудні заявив, що США вийдуть з договору
про ліквідацію ракет середньої та малої дальності,
якщо Росія не повернеться до дотримання договору протягом 60 днів.
Дедлайн 2 лютого, вже скоро.
Які шанси, що США вийдуть з договору?
Ми були вкрай чіткими. Ви згадали заяву держсекретаря в грудні
про те, що Росія суттєво порушила документ
і що ми ініціювали ось цей термін - 60 днів, як ви й сказали, до 2 лютого.
І якщо Росія не повернеться до дотримання цього договору до 2 лютого,
ми маємо намір призупинити наші зобов'язання за договором.
Я нещодавно була в НАТО й отримала повну підтримку від наших партнерів.
Договір абсолютно чіткий і його зобов'язання максимально зрозумілі.
На жаль, Росія продовжує їх порушувати.
Недотримання договору 2-го лютого призведе до припинення наших зобов'язань.
У чому різниця? Ви говорите не про вихід. Ви називаєте це призупиненням.
Я читала договір, там немає такого поняття - призупинення.
То в чому різниця?
Ні, є. Призупинення. Як ми й говорили, що ми призупинимо свою участь на шість місяців.
І з цього моменту йде відлік, протягом цього часу Росія може повернутися в рамки договору.
Але це звільняє нас від зобов'Язань за договором,
тобто ми припиняємо свої зобов'язання з наміром вийти,
якщо інша сторона не повернеться до виконання.
Ми будемо дотримуватися договору весь цей час,
призупинивши наші зобов'язання в частині того,
що ми зможемо займатися дослідженнями і розробкою систем,
аналогічних тим, що Росія зараз поставила на озброєння.
Тож у Росії буде ще шість місяців, щоб повернутися до дотримання договору?
Так, буде.
Що це за ракета, якою тепер нібито володіє Росія
і  яка порушує дію договору? Ви можете назвати її?
Звичайно. Це SSC-8, за класифікацією НАТО і США,
Росія знає, що це за система.
Ми зустрічалися з ними і показували їм інформацію розвідки,
яка доводить, що наявність цієї системи порушує договір.
Ми знову і знову говорили їм про дати тестових випробувань,
про місця, звідки були проведені тестові запуски.
Є розвідка, і є наші партнери, з якими ми теж поділилися інформацією.
Але вони все продовжували заперечувати,
що це були результати їхніх тестових випробувань.
Ми дуже багато працювали з нашими розвідслужбами заради отримання даних,
які ми могли б передати нашим партнерами у НАТО і нашим союзникам.
Усі наші партнери в НАТО і союзники продовжують закликати Росію,
виходячи з цієї інформації.
Вони підтримують наші зусилля з дотримування зобов'язань договору.
Але Росія так само заявляє, що США не дотримуються договору
і весь час як приклад наводять те, що США встановили систему ПРО в Румунії,
і там є ракетні установки, які порушують договір.
Це правда?
Вони не праві. Росія - єдина країна, яка продовжує порушувати це питання знову.
Інші партнери в НАТО і союзники продовжують говорити,
що США залишаються в рамках договору
про ліквідацію ракет середньої і меншої дальності.
Росія продовжує порушувати питання про гарантії крім усього іншого.
Ми неодноразово надавали факти й інформацію, яка підтверджує дотримання договору.
Ще раз: тільки одна країна це робить.
Наші партнери в НАТО, наші союзники - на одному боці з нами,
і ми продовжуємо повторювати, ґрунтуючись на фактах, на свідченнях, на даних розвідки,
і даємо Росії всю інформацію по цій системі.
А чи може Росія перевірити, що ці пускові установки відповідають договору?
Чи їй не дозволено перевірити протиракетну систему на місці, на базі в Румунії?
Право нерегулярно перевіряти системи одне одного не прописане в договорі.
Але повторюся, ми дали їм дані розвідки, космічні дані,
такі ж, як і нашим партнерам.  Але вони продовжують свою демагогію.
Це демагогія і пропаганда. Це смішно.
Ми намагаємося усвідомити причини, навіщо вони темнять і маскують порушення.
Світ бачить це шахрайство, як воно є,
і що це - порушення договору. І ми продовжуємо вважати їх відповідальними.
Ви очікуєте відновлення гонки озброєнь з Росією, з іншими країнами,
беручи до уваги, що Росія розробляє нові системи озброєнь?
Буде нова гонка озброєнь чи ні?
Я вже казала колегам, коли вони обговорювали виклики і серед них - гонку озброєнь.
Я нагадала їм, що Росія вже поставила на озброєння ці ракетні системи.
Росіяни явно порушили, і вони почали так звану гонку озброєнь.
Ми будемо продовжувати дотримуватися договору,
і ми почнемо свої розробки і дослідження,  якщо нам дозволять після 2 лютого,
ми почнемо розробляти свої системи, щоб захистити глобальні інтереси Сполучених Штатів.
І ми будемо працювати з нашими партнерами і союзниками. Це прекрасний приклад.
Якщо ми подивимося на глобальну ситуацію зараз,
яка істотно змінилася, і на ситуацію часів холодної війни,
що схоже і що відрізняється між цими часами?
Я, напевно, можу ще кілька інтерв'ю на цю тему дати, щоб описати обстановку і загрози.
Очевидно, технології змінилися. Партнерства змінилися,
сама форма загроз, загрози з боку радикального ісламу змінилися.
На щастя, у нас чудова команда. Ми постійно оцінюємо ситуацію,
працюємо з нашими партнерами з міністерства оборони, з іншими відомствами,
з партнерами і союзниками, де б це не було - на Близькому Сході, в Європі або в цІлому світі,
щоб найкраще захистити наші інтереси.
Як ви гадаєте, ситуація в сфері безпеки нині краща,
ніж та, що була за часів холодної війни?
Це ми не можемо порівнювати або протиставляти.
Світ у 80-і роки і тепер дуже різний.
Я служу своїй країні понад 30 років у різних військових точках і в різних конфліктних зонах.
Там є загрози, і ми будемо продовжувати мінімізувати
загрози нашими системами озброєнь,
нашими людьми і нашою роботою з партнерами і союзниками.
Пані заступнице держсекретаря, спасибі велике за інтерв'ю.
Дякую за цю можливість. Я дуже це ціную.